[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: So welcome back.
We're going to keep this
journey going on FinTech.
We spoke about payments
in our last class.
And here in Class 7, we're
going to dive into credit,
and there's a lot to cover.
There are so many different
segments and sectors
in the credit space, and
there's a lot going on
with financial technology,
not just because
of artificial intelligence,
Open API, but even
the earlier things that
were brought into the tech.
Now, technology stack around
mobile phones and the like
still gives a lot of
opportunity to break in here,
and the use of alternative data.
So I'm going to bring up--
share some slides
and get going here.
First, I should
also say to those
who celebrate such things,
happy Earth Day, April 22.
It's also my daughter's
birthday, my eldest,
my first daughter at 3.
So today's a special day, Earth
Day and my daughter's birthday.
So happy birthday, Anna.
So I'm going to do a
little update on Facebook.
We spoke about Facebook in
our last class about payments.
And there were interesting
announcements, actually,
as we were together.
Facebook was announcing
some updates.
And then dive into
the credit world.
And before we dive
into FinTech, just
talk a little bit about
those credit sectors
and the market designing credit.
And that provides,
as we'll see, some
of the disruptive potential
and how disruptive Taq
can break into the
credit value chain.
What you're always
looking for in a business,
whether it's about
FinTech or otherwise,
is somehow to break into
another party's value chain
or to create value
for customers.
Either you can create value
where others haven't seen it,
or you want to break into
somebody else's value chain.
So we'll talk a
little bit about that,
how we see that pretty
early in this area
of financial technology.
And then a review of the
competitive landscape
by the different marketplaces.
I'll touch on marketplace
lending and credit scoring,
and then I'll close with just
a comment on professionalism
and academic
integrity, as people
are gearing up for their papers
and group work, and so forth,
again.
The readings included a review
of 12 FinTech companies.
This was just a taste test.
It was one article in
reaction to Apple Credit Card.
And these were FinTech companies
in the credit card space.
But as we'll see
today, we're going
to review a lot of the
other spaces, as well.
A brief article
that I thought was
helpful about how
tech companies are
seeing how to get into the
lending business, big tech,
particularly.
Marketplace lenders,
we'll look at Lending Club
more particularly, and
then alternative data.
Study questions, again,
are not just for you
to gear up and
prepare for the class,
but this is where I
want to sort of end how
we can think about this, really
importantly, how big tech
firms are positioning
themselves to offer credit.
And I don't know,
Romain, if anybody
is going to sort of get
the cobwebs off and give us
some thoughts, but
I'm going to turn
it to Romain to see if there's
anybody that wants to just give
it a thought, broad overview
of big tech in this space,
whether it's from China,
Europe, the US, Latin America.
OK, let's go for today's class.
Who would like to be
the first volunteer?
Michael.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I guess
something from the article
that [INAUDIBLE] just kind of
seeing over the last decade,
what's going on, there's
been a lot more availability
of lending.
I think Lending Club was--
I kind of saw it more
from a personal investing
point of view, but kind of
thinking of who can actually
have access to credit has
been a huge position of tech
in the US, and also the speed
of the traditional credit
process for consumers
and small businesses
has been kind of painful.
So that's definitely a
big area that big tech
is trying to tackle with AI
and just automated processes.
GARY GENSLER: Right, right.
But Michael, if you add to it,
think about big tech companies.
How are big tech companies
strategically positioning
themselves?
I mean, Lending Club and
the marketplace lenders
are a very important
trend here, as well,
these sort of more
disruptive companies,
some of them becoming
incumbents in their space.
But how about big platforms?
I guess embedding it with their
current services, products
that they already have.
Like, Apple Pay
was a good example,
where it's just
kind of everybody's
already using an iPhone, so if
they can just make it seamless
with their existing processes.
So this is again
[INAUDIBLE]---- well,
I see a couple other hands up.
So, Romain?
TA: Alessandro?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think, also, Amazon is a
very interesting case where,
thanks to all the data, they
have gathered on sellers
from their marketplace,
they are able to offer
short-term lending to all the
sellers on the marketplace.
And this also gives them
a competitive advantage.
These would be banks,
commercial banks, first of all.
Because the notion of this
lending is very small.
So it's comparable
to microlending.
And second, because
they have access
to a huge amount of data on
the business of these sellers.
And third, they have a
direct accessed repayment.
Because basically,
these repayments
are automatic from the business
of the sellers on the Amazon
Marketplace.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So what Michael and
Alexandro have said is--
well, first, we talked a little
bit about the disruptors.
But in terms of
big tech, they have
a lot of network advantages,
whether it's Apple.
And there's so many
people that have
their phones and their
products, whether it's
Amazon in the case that--
Alexandro, we can go to
other countries as well.
This is certainly true in a
very significant way in China.
But if it's not just
isolated in China and the US
is that they have big
networks of users.
They collect data
and particularly
if you're a marketplace
like Amazon or Alibaba.
When you're selling
product, you're
seeing both sides of a market.
You're seeing the consumer
side, the hundreds of millions
of people in China or
the tens of millions
of people in the US.
But you're seeing
the merchant side.
And so that data, and that
flow, and that activity
gives you a natural
competitive edge.
And then lastly, what
was just mentioned
is automatic
payment, particularly
if you're in an online
platform selling something.
You see that merchant's
payment stream,
but also, you lower
the credit risk.
Because consumers are buying.
You take your piece to pay
back, whether it's a revolving
or term loan to a merchant.
So a lot of competitive
edges or even advantages
in this space for
them to build upon
to provide a credit product.
TA: Sijin would also
like to share a thought.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
the case of Alibaba
is really interesting.
Because just like
Gary had mentioned,
there are a lot of
transaction data
and also use their
data in Alibaba.
So right now, Alibaba not
only offer the payment system,
it also offer a credit system.
You can borrow
money from Alibaba.
Actually, it has its own
credit system that can--
I mean, the credit rating.
They can determine
how much money
you can borrow from Alibaba.
So I think this case
is fairly interesting.
GARY GENSLER:
Yeah, so two things
that I think I want to tease out
of that is the idea of building
credit on top of payments.
Now, this is not
a new phenomena.
This goes back centuries
that any good banker
knew that if you were in
the center of payments,
you had more information.
You had more data, even
in a pre-computer age.
But what we find is a lot
of the big tech companies
as well as the disruptors chose
to get into the payment space
and then build upon that credit.
Now, as it relates
to Alibaba, what
better way to do that
than to provide a payment
mechanism to purchase the
products on your platform,
similar with Amazon?
And then you can build
credit upon that.
Because you've got an
incredible amount of data.
But also, you can
provide credit in what's
called point-of-sale credit.
Buy something, pay for it over
6 weeks, 8 weeks, 10 weeks
when you're purchasing,
so good points.
So what is marketplace
lending, this phenomena
that started out at
the United Kingdom?
We'll talk a little
bit about LendingClub
here in the US, started about
a dozen to 15 years ago.
What is it in its theory?
And where is it right now?
Anybody want to chat
about that for a minute?
LendingClub, LendingTree--
a lot of companies
that we can chat about here.
TA: Alida?
AUDIENCE: Yes, the
marketplace [INAUDIBLE]
lending instead of the concept
of allowing individuals
to lend to other
individuals or companies
through a marketplace.
And while they've been
around for a while,
they've really just come
into lending platforms.
And they're really supported
by a securitization market
behind them now, rather
than individuals lending
on the platform
for the most part.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
Right.
And Michael spoke about
this earlier as well.
I think it's an
interesting concept,
but that it hasn't actually
lived up to its early promise.
The promise, when this
came about in 2005 to 2007,
was that you and I could use
the internet to communicate.
And I could lend to you, and
you could borrow from me,
peer to peer, without
a central intermediary.
Now, there was always going
to be some intermediary.
Because there was a platform, a
software provider taking a fee,
but somehow matching
lenders to borrowers
in a peer-to-peer network.
What we found over
these 13 or 15 years
is that the marketplace
lenders like LendingClub
have shifted to
securitization market
to raise their money, a
highly organized and somewhat
centralized market
securitization market.
And on the lending side,
you're still very much saying
that you're going
through a portal
and that there's only so
many of these portals.
So it's not that it's
truly peer to peer.
And in fact, often it's now
called marketplace lending
in its platforms.
I think that it's still
a very important part
of the disruptive
credit landscape,
but it's a small percentage
of that marketplace.
And it's shifting very
dramatically from peer
to peer to online portals.
It's still access centralized
credit in many ways.
And we'll see.
And we'll chat a
little bit about--
LendingClub is even now buying--
announced earlier in
2020 to buy a bank
and merged with the bank itself.
And then there's already
been some discussion
of alternative data,
but alternative data
building upon a history
in many countries
for four or five decades to use
data to make credit decisions
by changing it.
And I see a hand raised
on this, maybe, Romain?
Or no?
TA: I don't see
any hands raised.
I'm sure one will come up.
GARY GENSLER: Going down.
So where does that take us?
Let me go back to Facebook
Libra just for a moment.
And this is where we
closed our last class is
that Facebook Libra had
announced in June of 2019.
And then the People's
Bank of China
had already been working on
the digital currency project.
But then they sped that
up a bit and announced
within a month or two that
they were going to move forward
with their currency project.
Libra had announced
a token pegged
to four or five
other currencies,
so is a multi-currency basket.
And there was a lot of
push-back from central banks
around the globe on
this concept that they
would create what
Facebook actually
announced-- a global currency
for billions of people.
There was concern amongst
the G7 and G20 countries,
but there was also concern of
a broader group of countries
developing countries as
well as to what this meant
for their monetary policy, how
stable this would really be,
and whether it would
compete with fiat currencies
in not just a positive way,
but maybe a negative way.
And there were also a
lot of concerns about
whether it would support
and somehow become
the domain of illicit activity--
drug runners, and the
like, and so forth.
So Facebook is a big company.
They stub their toes
from time to time.
This might have been
one of those times,
but it was an
innovative project.
So they announced last
week some changes.
And most importantly
for this conversation--
and this is just a
slide taken from--
I think it was a
Medium post I found.
They said that Libra
would now be a platform.
And they would do
single currency tokens--
a euro token, a US dollar token,
a sterling token, et cetera,
et cetera.
They'll still have
a multi-basket,
a multi-currency basket
coin called Libra.
But they'll have what's, in
essence, stable value tokens.
And they feel that there's
still enough opportunity
or as what we talked about--
pain points in the payment
system that a dollar token, a
euro token, a British sterling
token, and the like is relevant
and an important layer.
What Libra also
announced is that they're
taking a tiered approach
to this whole topic
of anti-money laundering
and know your customer.
In essence, working with
governments around the globe,
they're saying they would only
work with wallet providers.
This would be single
currency wallet
providers or multi-currency
Libra wallet providers.
They'd only work with a
digital wallet provider
if it was in a jurisdiction
that had regulation
and those wallets
and exchanges, if it
was on a crypto exchange
were well regulated
within those countries or at
least regulated and registered
within those countries under
the guidance around the globe
that's issued by the FATF.
The Financial Action
Task Force is anti-money
laundering standard
setters around the globe.
And they had said
that they wanted
to take a tiered
approach that would even
include on the permissioned
blockchain in the protocol
layer, in the software
itself some protections
against sanctions.
Now, they didn't
say whether it was
sanctions that were UN
sanctions, European sanctions,
US sanctions.
And then you get into some
interesting geopolitical issues
as to how Libra,
the associations
would sort through this.
But it's interesting.
Facebook is not giving
up, just because there's
a lot of push-back.
And for those of you that
might watch this online
and might watch it
in 2021 or 2022--
but this course will have a life
for a while, offered online.
It'll be interesting
to look back
to see what other adjustments
at Facebook and Libra,
done in '20 and
2021, to continue
to meet the official sector and
bring this thing to life going
forward.
Any questions on Libra?
I had the opportunity.
They actually reached out to
me last week after our class.
And they wanted to give you a
little briefing to your faculty
member on this.
TA: I don't see any
hands raised, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So I'm going to
sneak into credit.
So what are the credit sectors?
I mean, we all know them.
This is pretty straightforward--
household sector
and corporate sector.
But the household
sector-- the big pieces.
And those of you that
took the half semester
of consumer finance
course remember all this--
mortgages, autos, credit cards,
personal loans, student loans.
And then you can
have sub-sectors.
If you're thinking about
disrupting this space,
you would think, all right,
where am I going to slice into?
Am I going to try to do
something in mortgages,
or credit cards, or where?
Am I going to try to go to
the high end, the low credit
risk super prime?
Or am I going to try to be
in the sub-prime marketplace?
And these markets are vast.
They're vast in
nearly every country.
So you'd pick and target what
you're actually going for
and literally whether you're
picking debt consolidation
or point-of-sale
lending matters as well.
The corporate sector
is interesting.
In terms of fintech,
the corporate sector
has been disrupted
dramatically in earlier decades
by the securitization markets.
And asset securitizations
happen primarily
around the household sector.
But asset
securitization or a way
to fund lending through
the securities markets
has come to the real
estate and more recently
to the collateralized loan
markets or CLO markets.
But in fact, when
we really think
about these markets,
what's been focused
on in terms of
financial disruption
is primarily the
household sector.
And then I circled
the small business
and small and
medium-sized enterprise.
Now, SME, mid-market
companies could
be defined all sorts of ways.
In the middle of this
corona crisis in the US,
we seem to have latched
on to companies that
are less than 500 employees.
It's not a specific definition
somewhere around the globe.
But large enterprises can
access the securities markets
directly.
Large enterprises
are, by and large,
borrowing from big banks
or securities markets.
And the greatest
opportunities have really
been in the small business
or SME market place.
And it could be products
like cash advance products,
purchased credit,
working capital lines.
We'll get a little
bit into this.
But again, if you're
thinking about credit,
it's a vast market.
And it's not one to just forget
about all the little pieces
in there.
Romain, I think there
were some questions.
Sure.
TA: Yes, we have a
question from Victor.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
see the point
of why [INAUDIBLE]
euro, dollar, whatever.
The stable dollar
already exceeds
in the cryptocurrency market.
And I even, in that case, fully
understand what [INAUDIBLE]
with less fees.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So, Romain, Victor was
cutting in and out.
I think, if I understood the
question, is back to Facebook
and why they have the stable
individual currencies,
but I'm not certain.
I'm sorry.
So around the globe,
there are definitely
shortcomings of our fiat payment
systems, these pain points.
Some of it just relates to
whether the payment systems
are 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
In terms of the euro, actually
the target payment system
run by the European Central Bank
does have attributes of 24/7.
The US-- we have more
challenges in that regard.
But the bigger issue often
in payment systems are costs.
And so what Facebook
Libra is saying is,
we can provide something that
can compete in this space.
But money is already
digital Fiat money,
the euro is already digital.
So Libra and Facebook
are not providing that.
They're saying this is
a different digital euro
or a different digital
dollar that can maybe
move 24 hours a day,
seven days a week
where you can get
instantaneous settlement.
Now, the US Federal
Reserve is moving there.
And we'll be there
by 2023 or '24.
And in fact, even in the
US, the clearinghouse,
as we talked about,
the organization
of about 24 major banks have
it in a continuous real time
payment system.
Europe is already moving to that
continuous real time payment
system.
So you might say, why would a
Libra euro compete with that?
Partly because it would be
on the Facebook platform.
And the thought is that
Facebook would embed it
into their system.
It's to some extent
to try to compete
with what Amazon, and
Alibaba, and Tencent
are doing elsewhere as well.
But implied in your
question is, so what?
Why would this matter?
And I think it's a
competitive landscape.
And time will tell us whether
it will really matter.
Because we already
had digital euros.
This would be a different
form of a digital euro.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of an overlap, I guess.
GARY GENSLER: That's right.
That's right.
TA: And I think, Gary,
on the same topic,
we might have a
question from Luke.
GARY GENSLER: It is.
Luke?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Again, Luke
is not coming through.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: I'm here.
So each question is, what
is the main difference
between Libra 1.0 and the 2.0?
Because 1.0, I believe, was
suggesting currency basket.
And second question was
regarding LendingClub.
It's down a lot--
42% in three months and
93% since five years.
And will it drive during this
consumer equity crunch that
is the quarantine
recession we have now
or suffer from high leverage?
Because it acquired a
brick and mortar bank,
which seems untimely these days.
And regarding the
currency basket,
wouldn't it suffer
during economy downturns
when there's a distortion
between safe currencies
such as the US dollar, Swiss
franc, and the emerging market
currency that is R&B or
whatever they're really
putting in the basket?
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
First, let me compliment.
I love the Edvard Munch
that you have behind you.
I assume it's just a visual.
But if it's an original,
protected safely.
To your second
question, LendingClub,
I think that all of
the marketplace lenders
have some challenges in the
middle of the corona crisis.
I think that their early promise
has improved that completely.
So you're right that it went--
it's a public
company, actually--
LendingClub.
It went public.
Its stock came off
dramatically, 70% or 80%,
even well before
this corona crisis.
Then within the crisis, it's
come off some more as well.
It's buying a bank.
It's not technically a
bricks and mortar bank.
That bank, I think, has one
location in Massachusetts,
maybe in Boston.
It's an online bank.
And what they're trying to do--
their theory of the
case is that they want
to lower their borrowing costs.
Because marketplace
lenders-- and we'll see this
in a moment--
arrange with some
banks to borrow money.
So marketplace lenders
are from the markets.
Some of it's securitized,
some from banks.
And what they're saying is,
we can maybe lower our costs
by embedding a bank.
Back to Libra, and
Facebook, and the like,
the main difference
between Libra 1.0 and 2.0
are the two that I mentioned.
I mean, they would say there's
three or four other changes.
But one is rather than only be
a multi-currency coin, Libra,
they're adding individual coins.
They're not getting rid of
the multi-currency coin.
The multi-currency
coin is still there.
It's still their aspiration
to have a multi-currency coin.
But they're adding
the single coins
to try to give a new euro
digital dollar to it.
And secondly, they're
adding much more--
know your customer anti-money
laundering regimes by saying,
look, we're only going to work
with digital wallets and crypto
exchanges in certain
jurisdictions which
are registered and following
anti-money laundering law.
And additionally, we'll embed
in the software some protocols,
literally in the software to
guard against either sanctions
and some other things.
Whether this will be enough to
satisfy the official sector,
yet to be seen.
It looks like they're moving
first with Switzerland
and trying to have Switzerland's
regulator, FINMA, capture
it and move forward.
I'll take one brief-- more
question, because we've
got a lot to cover, but sure.
TA: So Cindy had
her hand up for one.
If you want to talk,
unmute yourself, please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'll just ask briefly.
But with household
private sectors,
how are they preventing
against predatory lending?
Because just through reading
some of the articles,
it seems like that becomes a
gray line when you're targeting
specific type of
customer who doesn't
qualify for traditional loans.
GARY GENSLER: So you're talking
about more broadly, just
in terms of, how do we
guard in any country
against predatory lending?
It's hard.
The entire credit space
has a lot of protections
and regulations starting in--
well, I would say starting
hundreds of years ago, really.
One would even go back
to the Hammurabi Code
and say there was regulation
of interest rates.
But in the modern
days, we embedded--
let's take the US for a moment.
Two really important things.
One was the Equal
Credit Opportunity
Act or what some
people call ECOA,
which was in the
late 1960s and then
something called the Fair
Credit Reporting Act, I think,
by 1972.
These two came out of an earlier
way, the fintech, an earlier
wave of credit cards, an
earlier wave of lending
and directly to this question
about whether it was fair
and whether it was equal.
Everybody had the same access,
Equal Credit Opportunity Act,
that you couldn't differentiate
because of gender, or race,
or nationality, and the like
and Fair Credit Reporting,
that those credit reports.
The things that we came to know
and in about 30 countries rely
on, is these FICO scores from
a company called the Fair Isaac
company, that those scores--
we'd have to be able to
know something about them.
And if we were
turned down, somebody
has to explain to us
how we were turned down.
Well, now, fast forward to 2020.
Absolutely.
The question is right.
How can we protect that
we still have equal credit
and that it's explainable?
And why is somebody turned down?
And once somebody is not
allowed to take credit,
it gets tougher with artificial
intelligence and machine
learning.
It also gets tougher
when there's not
a physical location.
And thirdly, many
of these companies
are not regulated or
registered as banks.
And regulators around
the globe tended
to look to banks to make
sure that these laws were
fairly applied.
Now, they also look to the
credit reporting agencies.
So I think the real answer
is in these changing times,
the official sector
around the globe
has to adapt and sometimes
change a little bit of who
is regulated and even if you're
a non-bank, that you still
have to comply with some of
these things, importantly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: So
let me just give you
a sense of the size and scope.
The household sector--
you can look at this later
in the Canvas slides, but
the household sector--
grown dramatically.
And if you look in
the United States,
we're no longer the
top percent of GDP.
In fact, I think
Luke is in Korea now.
Your country is now peaked
up to be number two.
But look at China.
China from 10 to 20% of
GDP just 15 years ago.
And all of a sudden, 50% of GDP.
So these markets have grown
a lot in many countries.
I wouldn't just think
about this in the US.
And Brazil and India--
I would predict, will grow
significantly as well.
Now, in the US, we've got about
$14 trillion of household debt.
Before the corona crisis, we
had at $22 trillion economy.
And so you could
see it's about 2/3
of our economy, the underlying
consumer household debt.
The corporate sector--
very important as well.
But it's the household
sector dominated in the US
by mortgages--
2/3 of that 2/3 or about
$10 trillion, $11 trillion
of mortgage market.
But each of these markets
are really significant.
Even the auto lending market--
it might look small at these
numbers here, but they're not.
That's a big number
when you come at it
and if you wanted to
pursue that business.
And a little bit on the
non-financial corporate debt
market--
we'll see this shake out.
Post the corona crisis,
a lot of these numbers
will go up significantly.
And I would say one thing
just off the topic of fintech.
I think that though we
didn't enter this crisis
with a household debt
problem in most countries,
we had a real household debt
problem going into 2008 crisis.
While we didn't enter this
with a household debt crisis,
within three to six
months in most countries,
we will have a household
debt crisis, I fear.
Because the consumer sector
can't be supporting their auto
loans and credit card loans.
And one of the
reasons I think this
is unlikely to be
of the recession,
but it's going to be
a long U recession,
almost like it's
a bathtub trying
to get out the slippery
slopes of this recession,
is around the globe,
households are
going to have to repair
their balance sheets.
You're going to have to
slowly repair balance sheets.
And it's not going to
be easy, so true also
in the corporate
sector, most likely.
But the market design matters--
if you are creating
a fintech company,
you would think about
the market design.
And I'm not going
to dive into this.
But each one of these
pieces gives an opportunity
to break into the
credit markets.
It might be around data.
You might have a particular area
that you could do better data
or like Credit Karma.
Credit Karma was really about
providing free credit scoring.
Think about this-- just
free credit scores.
And Credit Karma then
could cross sell and market
your products Credit
Karma company was
formed less than 10 years
ago, sold earlier in 2020
for $5 billion to
Intuit, Intuit that
has the TurboTax,
and this accounting
software, and the like.
But Credit Karma had 106
million individual files
on various folks, not all
of whom are their customers.
But they cross sell.
They had nearly a billion
dollars in revenue in 2019.
It might be on the funding side.
You might have a new way to do
securitization or your issuer
bank partnership.
And we talked about.
LendingClub had an
issuer bank partner.
Now, they're trying
to buy a bank.
It might be on the funding side.
And that's what peer-to-peer
lending tried to do.
And they haven't been
as broadly successful.
Most importantly, I would
say that it's usually
been on user experience
and user interface.
And sometimes it's that you
got in through the payment
channels, like Toast getting
into the restaurant sector
through the payment.
Toast was a company
out of Boston.
It was really about software.
It was about
tablets and hardware
as well, that the restaurant
server had a better user
experience.
And the restaurant had
a better experience
in the tablet and payment side.
And then they started
to build Toast credit
to provide those
restaurants credit.
Now, there's going to be a
shakeout there, no doubt,
in terms of this crisis,
the corona crisis.
It might be that you're breaking
into some slice of risk.
And this has been a case
for a lot of companies
that have broken into manage
one risk or another better.
And then lastly,
what role are you in?
In the mortgage markets here
in the US-- and we found
that origination
has really changed.
And we'll look at the
competitive landscape.
But companies like Quicken
Loan, and PennyMac, and others
have broken in.
And they've broken in
on the origination side.
And that's partly because the
uniqueness in the US mortgage
market--
that our government-sponsored
enterprises guarantee
the bulk of the market.
So the balance sheet
credit risk is diminished.
And Quicken Loan, and PennyMac,
and others can come in.
And probably over
half the market
is originated by
companies that are broadly
speaking disruptors.
So again, it could be data.
It could be funding.
It could be the user
experience, which
is really a critical one,
maybe the risks, the roles.
Any piece of these might
give an opportunity
to break into a market or
to do something different
than the financial incumbents.
So the earlier
fintech, way back--
I'm going to take you to a
story about an earlier fintech
that I like.
It's just credit cards.
The first use of
the term credit card
was in the 1880s
in a dystopian--
I would call it, but
utopian book that
was written by Edward Bellamy.
It was a New York
Times bestseller.
It was a bestseller in multiple
languages around the globe,
talking about the year 2000.
Well, Bellamy-- you could go
back and look at the book.
It's really science fiction.
But use the term credit card.
It's the first known
use of the concept
that you would have
a card for payments.
Well, shortly thereafter, not
really because of Bellamy,
you saw a bunch of companies
starting to use charge coins
and charge cards.
And by the 1920s,
these merchant cards--
you had an individual merchant
providing credit and saying you
can buy something on credit.
You could call that a
point-of-sale credit.
Earlier fintech-- about
a hundred years ago.
But in the 1940s, one
banker in Brooklyn
never made a lot of
money for themselves.
One banker came up with the
concept of a credit system
where it was multiple merchants.
Not one merchant, but
multiple merchants.
And that charge card--
75 years ago, so a long time
ago, but still somewhat recent.
And that led to
the 1940s and '50s,
all these innovations--
the first plastic card.
BankAmericard was from
a California bank.
And that's where Visa started.
So all of that was
fintech of the time.
And the only reason
I mention it is
if you think about what
disruptions have come before
that now we take for
granted, sometimes
that's evidence in
what you might do now.
BankAmericard was
a California bank
that was trying to partner with
other banks around the country
and partnered with
other countries
to do something that was more
universal for the country.
The Diners Club was literally
about this restaurant concept.
You would consider it almost
like a general merchant
card, an early Toast.
The Diners Club did
what maybe Toast
is trying to do now,
inside the restaurants,
providing more use of those
initially high-end restaurants
on the East Coast.
So what disruptions are
in the value chain now?
And particularly,
this little chart--
I borrow from an interesting
long paper on it,
is think about the different
parts of the value chain.
Whether you're sourcing
capital, you're
actually assessing credit.
That's the underwriting
of the credit
or actually just
servicing the credit
like you're servicing
a student loan.
It can be any part
of the value chain.
And you could go in and disrupt.
And we're not going to
dive into this chart.
But I'll just take
disbursements for a minute.
If you look at that
vertical, it could
be digital wallets,
or virtual currency,
or the machine learning.
If it's in credit assessment, it
could be the alternative data.
So each of these provides
a little opportunity
to disrupt the current
business model.
And so we talked about
payments last class, credit.
You really have to
get, in a sense,
granular into which
part of the value chain.
And then, how do I
bring a technology to it
that maybe the big
incumbents aren't yet
doing in a sufficiently
sophisticated way?
Or you might just
bring it to one sector
like Toast did to the
restaurant sector.
It might be sector specific.
So where do we go?
Well, we've already
seen big techs there,
the payment unicorns.
There's hundreds of
other payment companies
that are building credit
on top of payment.
And sometimes a payment
company is really also a credit
company, like Brex is
both payment and credit.
AvidXchange is mostly
payment, but is
moving into credit and then some
that are built just on credit.
And so I thought I would
start with the business side--
small, medium-sized
enterprise lending.
Again, there's no really
good definition of SME.
But the definition that these
companies would take at it--
they would say
these are companies
that are having difficulty
borrowing from the big banks.
It's either assessing
credit or providing
that credit in a timely
and a cost-effective way.
Brex is an interesting company
that started around the concept
that, I can't get
money as a startup.
How can I even get a
credit card if I had a--
it's a mixture of seed investing
and credit card provisions.
Some of these companies I
put on here like Amazon,
Alipay are big tech.
I don't think you
can leave them out.
Some started in the
payment side like Square
and Stripe and Toast--
which I mentioned earlier--
PayPal.
All provide small and
medium-sized enterprise
lending.
Some are really just
like Kabbage and Lendio,
provide comparison, that you can
go on the Lendio prop platform,
and you can compare
and contrast.
They're more like a
broker or an agent
than actually
making the lending.
And Funding Circle is
one of the only ones
that is a little bit in
the marketplace lending.
Do I see some questions, Romain?
I'm doing a thumbnail
taste test here.
TA: So in the chat,
there's quite some activity
about LendingClub.
Perhaps you can
provide the class
with an overview of
their business model.
And what are the challenges
they've been facing?
GARY GENSLER: All right.
I'm going to do that
in about 10 minutes.
So I'll hold that if I can.
LendingClub has been more
about the household sector
than the small and medium size.
I'll ask this.
Has anybody in the
class actually worked
at a startup, worked at any
corporation that's barred
from one of these companies?
TA: Alida, you've
unmuted yourself.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
at Citibank at the time,
that Citibank partners with
C2FO as a partnered [INAUDIBLE]
program.
We financed some of the smaller
suppliers in those programs
by large [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: So
it's interesting.
Could you share?
Why did Citibank partner
with C2FO, rather than
make those loans themselves?
And this is an important--
the relationship
with the incumbents
between the disruptors.
Why in that one
circumstance do you
think Citi chose to partner,
rather than do it on their own?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] an
interesting model that actually
allows the corporate to
lend to its suppliers
is the easiest way
to say it would
have been short-term firm.
But if you look at a
company and supplier base,
you'll see that 80/20
rule applies fairly well.
So the top 20
suppliers are generally
supplying appropriate with the
majority of their inventory.
[INAUDIBLE] Purchasing on that
bottom tail of the suppliers
is--
they're all very
small businesses.
They're hard to lend to.
It's very hard to do all
the KYC requirements, which
is really what Citibank does
not like doing [INAUDIBLE]..
And so a company
like C2FO could come
in there, partner with
a corporate [INAUDIBLE],,
and lend to or extend credit
to a supplier [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: So this
is an important aspect
that Alida just raised.
Large incumbents
sometimes don't feel
that they can, in a
cost-effective way,
assess the credit and
reach the distribution
to small businesses.
And then the disruptive
companies say, well, wait,
we could provide.
That's a little
crack in the system.
That's something we can have
more financial inclusion,
whether it's Brex
for the startups,
C2FO for a lot of the small
businesses, and the like.
And the incumbents say
all right, we can't.
But we can, through C2FO
and others, reach them.
And then it helps
down the supply chain.
I think Ivy's hand
was up, maybe?
TA: Yes, correct.
Ivy, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I use to work
in securitization.
And Brex is one of my
clients and then also worked
at a startup that
uses Brex, too.
And so I think, though,
to your point of--
their user interface
is pretty amazing.
And they've also just
have really identified
this white space of startups.
But I think where
we got comfortable
in terms of the diligence is the
fact that they're pretty much--
it's a very elegant way of just
having these startups making
sure that they have literally
enough cash in the account.
So they're monitoring that.
Basically, if you have
access to these startups,
bank account, day to day.
And they started with startups.
And they've been very, I
think, thoughtful about which
sectors they're going to, like
life sciences, and e-commerce,
and now having cash management,
which also makes a lot of sense
in terms of just having
yield, so just wanted to offer
a little bit more color there.
GARY GENSLER: And Brex
started with this concept
of, how does entrepreneurs
get money when you
don't have any track record?
Right?
Literally, you don't
have any track record.
They had to also
rely on something
we've talked about already--
OpenAPI.
They had to get data.
And they had to do
it, as you said,
in an efficient, elegant way to
get that data and get access.
Do you have cash in your
account, so to speak?
And now, they've grown
up a certain expertise
in that startup world.
And it's not equity
that they're funding.
It's loans, basically,
against the cash flow.
What you'll see also
on here is, as I
said, some of the big
tech companies like Amazon
and Tencent and Alipay.
You see some of the really,
now incumbent fintechs,
as some folks would call
them, like Stripe and Square
and PayPal and Intuit that have
built up a long history now,
either in the payment space or
in the tax prep and accounting
space, as some have
come from accounting.
Some have come from
the payment side
where they're getting data
and corporate business
relationships.
What you don't see is a
lot of the challenger banks
that we're going to talk
about in our next class.
Now, Prosper is here.
They've started to
offer some lending
side to the corporate side.
Most of the challenger
banks and nearly all
of the marketplace
lenders that are of size
are in the household
sector, rather than
the corporate sector,
which I find of interest.
I don't if there's a question.
TA: We have two hands raised--
Camillo and then Carlos.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
And then we're going to go
to the household sector.
AUDIENCE: OK, this is
about the household.
I'm sure you know about this
Brazilian unicorn called
Nubank.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, absolutely.
Yeah.
And we're going to be talking
about Nubank a fair amount
next Monday as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I just want to know--
well, maybe next class.
Do you think that their
business model about giving
online credit cards to--
I don't know.
I think it's 8.5 million people
already, who have a Nubank
credit card, is sustainable.
Because I don't know what's
their specific innovation,
apart from accepting
applications
on line of credit cards.
Just I'm wondering if
that's going to be--
are they are going to have
some [INAUDIBLE] problem?
GARY GENSLER: We'll dive more
into Nubank in the next class.
But let me just
generically say, I
think that it's the
reality of startups that
more will fail than succeed.
Now, as it specifically
relates to credit cards,
in the credit card
space, the big incumbents
aren't going to keep
the whole market.
And maybe that leads
me for a minute.
I'm going to come back
to mortgages in a second.
This is the US
credit card system.
It's not Brazil.
But the big seven, what
I call, or the big eight
being the big four
or five banks--
American Express,
Discover, and Cap One--
control 80%, 78%
as of last year--
credit card business.
There are a lot of
economies of scale.
There's a lot of economies of
scale back to managing risk
and balance sheet.
Credit cards as
opposed to mortgages
are not guaranteed in any
way by the US government.
It has a very
different risk profile.
This is about a little over
$1 trillion asset class market
in the US.
But 22% are smaller providers.
And so Amazon, for instance,
partners with Synchrony Bank.
And Amazon has the
Synchrony card.
Amazon also, I think, has
something with JP Morgan
as well.
You'd probably say Amazon
will be sustainable.
Amazon is such a phenomenal
profit generator,
particularly with
the crisis now.
I can't speak to
any one startup.
Can they chip away at this 22%?
Yes, they can by using
alternative data.
But the big seven or
eight are not asleep.
They're not ignoring
alternative data.
But a new startup
can say, maybe we
can approach this
in a different way
and particularly provide
a better user interface.
Here in the US, what's happening
is rather than credit card
products, they're
providing personal loans.
But let me hold on
that for a second,
because I want to go back
to the mortgage market.
I mentioned this in
the mortgage market.
These are figures from 2018.
These are the largest mortgage
originators in the US.
It doesn't mean that
they bought these loans
and held them on
their balance sheet.
The yellow are the non-banks.
And PennyMac, for some
reason, is not on here.
They should be.
But of the top 10, 5,
the yellow are non-banks.
Now, do we call them fintechs?
Absolutely.
They are giving a different
user interface with the public,
and they've just taken off.
Part of it is regulatory.
Part of it is since
the 2008 crisis.
Holding loans on
the balance sheets
become less attractive
to the big banks.
In terms of their capital
charges and the like,
part of it is also
because in the US,
this is highly tied to
the government-sponsored
enterprises.
But big disruption in the
last 12 years, that about half
of the loans are originated
by, broadly speaking,
yeah, the non-banks sector who
are largely then laying it off
to the asset
securitization marketplace.
Disruption of the past--
I believe there'll
still be disruption
in the future in this space.
Back to the credit
card side, what we
were talking about
there with Camillo--
and I'll pause if
there's other questions.
I just want to take
a look also at China.
China's biggest
credit card issuers--
all that are building upon
that UnionPay platform
we talked about.
UnionPay was started by, I
think, 84 banks in China,
really with the People's Bank
of China bringing that together.
UnionPay is that one backbone of
their whole credit card payment
system.
Interestingly, as dominant and
as strong as Alipay and WeChat
Pay are--
and in a sense,
WeChat Pay and Alipay
leapfrogged the banking system.
There's real growth going on
in the credit card business,
but not from disruptors
and startups.
It's like the commercial
banks getting back into it.
Romain where there
some questions?
TA: Yes, Alessandro?
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Yes, Gary.
I'd like to get your point of
view on the following topic.
So I was thinking about
how these new credit card--
think that companies work.
And most of them,
not all of them--
they got to partner up
with the bank, right?
Unless they have huge
amount of cash anticipated,
they got to partner up with a
bank that gives actual credit.
GARY GENSLER: Let me just pause.
They either have to partner
with a bank, which is the issuer
bank partner model.
And we're going to get to
LendingClub, I promise,
that has that issuer partner,
that bank that's a partner.
Or they tap into the
securitization markets.
And so for those who
are not familiar,
asset securitization
is the concept
that the securities markets
are the investors in the loans,
rather than holding
it on a bank's balance
sheet or a finance
company's balance sheet.
And that innovation, asset
securitization starting
in the mortgage markets
40-plus years ago moved
to the credit card markets
in a robust way by the 1990s,
is a very real way
to lay off that side,
meaning find somebody
else to be the investors,
rather than have
a balance sheet.
So back to you, Alexandro.
It's either a partner bank
or asset securitization.
AUDIENCE: So in the
end, these guys,
these fintech companies are
second intermediary, right?
So how much money do
they actually make?
Because I'm thinking the more
and more companies we can see,
the fees are going to go down.
So competition will
drive their fees down.
They also have to
pay a fee to-- you'd
see they're a balance
sheet bank or in the case
of securitization, too.
GARY GENSLER: So you're
absolutely right.
But financial intermediation
has multiple layers.
And the more advanced
an economy is, usually
the more the layers.
And the more competition in
the market, more the layers.
And you might think of
layers as inefficiency.
It might be.
But often, layers would bring
efficiency and competition.
So some financial firm
is doing the origination.
This is brokering and selling
and providing a user interface.
And they might not want to
be the balance sheet lender.
They might say, I'm going
to partner with the bank
to be the balance sheet lender.
What we're going to do is
we're going to compete and give
the most remarkable, robust
user interface and brokerage.
In the mortgage market, back to
that, the Quickens, and United
Wholesale Mortgage, and
PennyMac that aren't on here,
by and large, only hold the
mortgage for a few weeks,
a few days, maybe
a couple months.
They have a warehouse
line of credit to do that.
And then they
securitize the rest.
But the mortgage
market in the US
has a very robust
securitization market.
You asked about credit cards.
Credit cards-- this 22%
that's competing with the rest
does not have as big a
robust securitization market.
Of the trillion
in the US, I think
the credit card securitization
market is about $150 to $200
billion if I recall.
So it's harder.
But it might be that company,
the Nubank, as Camillo asked,
that has a better use of
underwriting, and data,
and so forth.
What somebody wouldn't give
for Credit Karma's data
with 106 million files?
That's a robust data set.
Now, Intuit, we know,
paid $5 billion.
So maybe we do know what
somebody would pay for it
I wouldn't diminish being
at one particular slice.
If you can find the
slice in the value chain
and compete away some of
the incumbent's margin,
credit cards are very big
business-- trillion dollars
in the US, very big in
Europe and Asia as well,
growing in China rapidly.
And there's a lot of margin.
I would say the thing
that's competing the most--
and I'm going to jump ahead.
But, Alexandro, stay
with us for a minute--
is the personal loan business.
Personal loans differ
from credit cards
in an important way, is that
credit cards are what's known
as a revolving line of credit.
Each purchase adds to
your credit balance.
You have a limit.
If you're high, if you're super
prime or a prime borrower,
your limit is higher.
If you're sub-prime,
your limit is lower.
That business of
revolving credit--
about a trillion
dollars in the US.
We now have this
personal loan business.
It's only about one sixth
the size, about $160 billion
in the US.
That personal loan
business is generally
term financing, a
specific term that you
have to have an installment loan
and pay once every month for 36
months or for 48 or 60 months.
The underwriting
risk of a term loan
is lower than the underwriting
risk of credit card
business or revolving credit.
The personal loan business is
where most of the disruptors
are.
The SoFis, and the Prospers,
and the Nubanks, and so forth--
they're trying to break
in the personal loan
side as much or even more
than the credit card side.
But I don't know if--
Alexandro, did you want
to follow up on anything?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
My point was just--
I don't know if you
agree on the fact
that we would see a
massive wave of mergers
between these companies.
I mean, in my mind, there's
not much room for all
of these hundreds of
companies that are just
popping up like mushrooms here.
GARY GENSLER: I think
we'll see mergers.
And I think we'll see failures.
But the question is,
is there an opportunity
in the midst of all of that?
Is there an opportunity
along the way?
We've seen in the payment
space a lot of consolidation
and the payment system
providers, the PSPs.
But there's still a
lot of opportunity
for sector-specific
payment companies.
And we've even seen that the
data aggregators in the payment
space have started to
combine and be bought
where that phase of things.
I think in the
household credit space,
we're going to see still
a lot of competition--
personal loan.
And I think in the
personal loan side,
they will be chipping away
at some of the profit margin,
so will be trying to, at least,
of the incumbents in the credit
card space.
And interestingly in China,
the credit card space
is trying to chip away at what
Alipay and WeChat Pay built up.
Because there was a reverse
over there that's happened.
Whether they'll be completely
successful-- another story.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE]
TA: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry.
So I have a question
on that point
that you brought up on UnionPay
being an attractive alternative
to Alipay and WeChat Pay.
GARY GENSLER:
[INAUDIBLE] I'm just
going to say it's been growing
more quickly than I might
have thought, that
I wouldn't count out
credit cards in China.
They've been growing.
AUDIENCE: Would you know what
were the value propositions
of UnionPay that liked
their consumers to opt
to its UnionPay?
Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Well, I'm not--
I mean, maybe some of our fellow
students know better than I.
But I think, listen,
you can't count out
that there's a distribution
channel when you have
84 banks and particularly the
six or eight big banks in China
that own a piece [INAUDIBLE]
and all the hundreds of millions
of people there.
They're not asleep.
As big tech comes in, the
incumbents don't rest.
It's competition.
But they do have the advantages
of incredible distribution
channel, meaning the depositors
and clients of those banks.
The product itself, the
revolving credit product,
the classic credit
card product has
a little bit more flexibility
than something just
on an e-money wallet.
And it doesn't mean
Alipay and WeChat Pay
can't offer something that
is pretty much identical
to a credit card [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's right.
GARY GENSLER: But their
balances and the like
might be different
as well, but I'm not
sufficiently close to it.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: And I might
pull some data for next class.
I'll show you what I'm
talking about there.
Personal loan business--
just to give you
a percentage of unsecured
personal loans, who is
making unsecured personal loan?
And again, a personal loan
is not tied to a credit card.
It's usually an
installment or term loan.
But you can see the shift
just in these five years,
that the disruptors are
eating into the market
share in this space.
Here are some of the
personal loan companies.
Not a lot of overlap.
Prosper is on both lists.
But not a lot of
overlap with the list
to the small and medium size.
And Camillo, I'm glad
I have NuBank on here.
But we'll come back
to a few of these
when we talk about
challenger banks--
Revolut, Nubank.
A number of these are
really what we also
call as challenger banks.
Student loans-- I could probably
ask for a show of hands.
How many of you have a
student loan by one of these?
And in the US, the private
student loan market
is only a small share.
Student loans in
the US are dominated
by our Department of Education.
Over 92% of student
loans in America
are either guaranteed or direct
loans from the Department
of Education.
But of course, the
private loan market
where graduate students and
particularly those who are not
US citizens are more likely
in the private student loan
market.
These are probably familiar
names to many of you,
whether you used MPower, or
Prodigy, or others, basically
to shop for a student
loan or a traditional bank
like SunTrust and Wells Fargo.
And that 8% of that market is
still about $100-plus billion.
Because the overall student
loan market is $1.6 trillion,
so not small numbers.
So marketplace lending--
I did say we would get to this.
It's an online
platform connecting
borrowers and investors.
So it's a platform
in the middle,
started with this concept
of being peer to peer.
And so this is a
look at LendingClub
from their own documents
from last summer.
LendingClub-- 3 million-plus
borrowers on one side
of the platform economics,
200,000-plus investors
on the other side.
Now, don't think of it
as 3 million and 200,000,
because it gets more
concentrated than that.
But LendingClub
sits in the middle,
between borrowers and
investors, or you might
call lenders, but investors.
But they partner
with issuing bank.
They don't want to take a lot
of this on their balance sheet.
They take some of it
onto their balance sheet.
But they want to basically have
issuing bank partners plural,
because they keep some
banks in competition.
And so what LendingClub
is providing
is the platform and some
of those issuing banks.
They're not the
Bank of Americas,
but they're much smaller banks.
Say, all right, we don't
have that front end.
We don't have that platform,
that user experience.
LendingClub provides that.
And the investors on the
other side of a LendingClub
are often hedge funds.
And asset managers are
saying we can invest.
LendingClub is providing
us a portfolio of loans.
And you can see
the numbers here--
16-month average
duration, 1 and 1.6 to 7
and 1/2% range of returns.
That's a pretty wide
range of returns.
And who are they?
Managed accounts means it could
be an account at BlackRock
or Fidelity that
says, we're going
to put a little bit of
money into this credit
market and the like.
Now, Luke was right.
LendingClub and many of the
other marketplace lenders
were quite a dream.
LendingClub happened
to go public.
And then their market
value came down quite a bit
as they had to prove out
whether they can make money.
Where have they been
in these last 10 years,
just to give you a sense?
In 2010, only it was $100
million of originations.
But it was all retail
originations, by and large.
By 2018, the retail, which
is a very small part of it--
they're originating very--
quite a different bit
of loans, how they're
originating these things.
And China-- I just
want to mention
China went through a remarkable
wave of peer-to-peer lending.
And then the People's
Bank of China
felt, no, we've got to
get control of this.
I mean, literally there was
2,700 peer-to-peer lending
platforms in China
just 4 years ago
and most recent statistics
down to about 300-plus.
And in November of 2019,
the official sector in China
still said this isn't right.
The peer-to-peer lenders
need more regulation.
In essence, they need
bank-like regulation.
And what's interesting
is back to LendingClub,
LendingClub has
actually announced
the purchase of a bank.
Romain, I think I
saw a hand go up.
TA: I don't see any, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, OK.
But there were questions
earlier about LendingClub.
TA: Yeah.
So now, we have
two hands raised.
Let's go first with Jose.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I'm not
super familiar with LendingClub,
but I'm familiar with
another one in Europe.
I think the way it works
is a bit different.
I would like to hear your
opinion on that model.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
GARY GENSLER: I'm listening.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's called Mintos.
I think it's the
biggest one in Europe.
And basically, what
they do is there's
a group of loan originators that
are independent companies that
create these loans and
give out these loans.
And then these [AUDIO OUT]
[INAUDIBLE] loans
to independent investors.
But they guarantee the
payment of the loan.
So if the person that asked
for the loan doesn't pay,
the loan originator pays for
that payment to the investor.
So basically, the
risk for the investor
is that the loan
originators go bankrupt.
I learned there's something
similar in the US to that.
GARY GENSLER: Well,
so what you're saying
is how they are
managing the risks.
The investors are
taking a credit risk
on the platform, the
originator, rather
than taking a credit risk on the
portfolio of loans themselves.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --one more
layer in between.
So there's the loan originators.
And there's hundreds
of companies, then
the platform that
connects the loan
originators with investors.
And basically, the investors
invest in specific loans,
but they are guaranteed
by the loan originators.
GARY GENSLER: Why
don't we do this?
Why don't you shoot me an email?
And I'll try to take this
up in our next class.
And I'll look at the
company more specifically.
But to the point,
there's no reason
you can't find a new model as
to who takes the credit risk.
Credit risk is
inherent in lending.
Somebody is going
to repay on time.
And others are going to fall
into delinquency or even
default. And so
then the structure
of a market, whether
it's mortgages,
credit cards, personal
loans, small businesses--
the structure of a
market might evolve
as to how to slice up who
bears that credit risk.
And there's not
just credit risk.
There's prepayment risk.
There's interest rate risk.
There's numerous
financial risks.
And so what's just being
highlighted by Jose--
and I apologize.
I just don't know that model,
is that the investors, rather
than bearing the direct
credit risk of the borrowers
are having some of
that held by others.
And they're bearing the
risk of the intermediary
in between the platform.
And in essence, that's
true in the US mortgage
market, a very different
part, what you asked about.
But the US mortgage
market conforming loans
are guaranteed by the government
or by the government-sponsored
enterprises so that
your risks then
are a little bit different.
It's not the credit risk.
In the US mortgage market,
you have prepayment risk.
Will somebody pay
the mortgage early
as interest rates might
go down and so forth?
And then in parts of the
US mortgage market that
are not the conforming
mortgage market,
you did have credit risk.
Because the government
wasn't guaranteeing.
And a lot of the
sub-prime mortgage
mess that we got into
in 2008 was around that.
But rather than taking
time now, why don't you
shoot me an email?
I'll look at this specific
company and come back.
Romain, were there
other hands up?
TA: Yes, let's go with Akshay.
AUDIENCE: Hello, professor.
So I had no question with the
business model of LendingClub.
So what is the role of
issuing banks in this case?
GARY GENSLER: So issuing
banks basically are
lending their balance sheet.
So let's say an issuing bank
has its own availability
of depositors and has not built
the front end to the borrowers.
So the issuing bank is
standing in to do that.
In addition, they're actually
papering and documenting
the loans.
So as you see on
this chart here,
the issuing bank is sending
the loans out and taking it in.
So there's a regulatory reason
that the issuing bank is there.
So the issuing bank might
issue the loans and hold them.
Or the issuing bank
might issue the loans
and then, literally,
as this chart shows,
resell them to LendingClub.
And LendingClub sells
them to investors.
So there's a bit of--
it's similar to what's
called a warehouse line.
The issuing bank
is standing there
ready to take loans,
but then resell them.
Because their capability
is only a certain size.
LendingClub says they
did $10 billion of loans
in 2018, if I recall the number.
The issuing bank doesn't
want to put $10 billion on.
But they're providing
the liquidity
for the first few days or weeks
until LendingClub then provides
the investor to buy the loan.
So it's similar to
a warehouse line,
but it's actually a
purchase and sale.
They purchase the loan or
issue the loan and sell.
There's also a bit of
regulation that you actually
have a bank involved.
And part of what was going
on, both in the UK and the US,
is this marketplace.
Peer-to-peer lending
started, is the platforms
didn't want to,
frankly, register
and be regulated like banks.
They needed somebody
else to make the loan
to have that interface.
I oversimplified.
And probably a lawyer would tell
me I've gotten it a little bit
wrong.
TA: And then we have Adam
who would like to provide
some insight on UnionPay.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
Please.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
closed on alternative data.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In response to [INAUDIBLE]'s's
earlier question
about UnionPay, so UnionPay is
a state-owned credit and debit
card network, all right?
So the one thing that separates
them from the [INAUDIBLE]
duopoly between
Alipay and WeChat Pay,
which dominates 90% of the
market, is that it can be,
well, among other things.
They can be used for all mobile
devices and computer browsers.
So technology wise, they
do have an advantage.
Because for WeChat
Pay, it's quite
restrictive in
terms of technology,
because they're used
mostly on mobile.
And unlike Alipay
and WeChat Pay,
UnionPay actually supports
almost all currencies
and operates in many
countries besides China,
also a feature that
both Alipay and WeChat
Pay are struggling with,
due to the peculiarities
of the Chinese legislation.
And the one thing is that
what UnionPay focuses on
is the fact that they
focus on the efforts
of those Chinese
account holders.
Because most people--
in fact, the majority
of the people who owns a credit
card will be UnionPay holders.
They are focusing on people who
travel abroad, predominantly
to the US, in fact.
So you see a lot
of shops that are
targeting for Chinese
customers and travelers.
You would see that UnionPay.
They could actually
pay by UnionPay.
So these are the edge that they
have over Alipay and WeChat
Pay.
And that's just in response
to the earlier question
[INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
What I'm going to do is--
because we only have two
minutes, is I'm going to hold
off and talk about alternative
data when we start up our next
session on challenger banks
and the like and just close
out with a little comment,
if I might, on just to--
what I've already said in our
first class on professionalism.
Hope this slide is there.
But again, is that I just
want to lend to you again
from my years of experience.
We're in a very unusual time
now with the corona crisis.
And we're even at MIT.
It's these Zoom classes and pass
emergency, no credit emergency,
and the like.
But I would just share with
you my own observation,
that for those of you trying
to get the most out of this MIT
experience, it's not easy.
And in some ways, it's just
frustrating as heck, I'm sure.
But again, to the
extent that you
can, to the extent you
can come prepared, and be
curious, and reach out to
faculty members like myself,
and leverage off of our
experience, take office hours,
I would do it.
I know this is a lousy time.
A lousy time.
I'm just reminding
us all of that
and saying take whatever you
can out of this MIT experience,
even if it's
diminished in some way.
I want to make myself
available again.
If you find the readings
of interest, do them.
If you can't get through them
because you're distracted
and you're looking
for a job, I get that.
I get that.
I'm just saying the
more you engage,
the more you will invest in
yourselves and get out of it.
And on plagiarism--
and I say this just
to remind people again.
There's probably-- it's going
to be hard for any of you--
get no credit emergency.
But somebody might get no
credit emergency if you submit
a 1,000-word paper and 600
or 800 words are plagiarized.
That's your pathway right
into that no credit emergency.
It's easy to avoid,
because you know
if you're taking a lot
from something else.
And I just say this, because
I have had those experiences.
I just mention it
again, just because I
want to do you the favor of
helping you make sure that even
in these unusual times,
that you protect yourself
if you want to get these 9
credits on your transcript.
But mostly, I put this up again
at this part of the semester,
just to say, we want to make
this MIT experience as good,
given all the
challenges as we can.
And we know it's a
heck of a crazy time.
But to the extent you want
me off hours or another time
or you've got questions that
I'll further research, just let
me know.
Or if you have a fintech
startup, let me know.
And I'll be all there.
And I'll read that, too.
I had one student
recently send me
a whole paper on a fintech
startup, just outside of this.
It's not an assignment.
But they're engaged
in a startup.
And I'm going to review
it and give some feedback.